[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es eine super saison motiv
torte und zwar nicht nur weil sie es
schmeckt sondern auch sie es aussieht
und zwar ist diese motiv torte für das
beste freundin luisa die wird nämlich
heute ein jahr alt und ich durfte ihr
die torte machen und gewünscht hat sich
meine freundin sabrina und jemand partie
die haben sich eine helle tore gewünscht
mit etwas fruchtigem und deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht mach' ich einen hellen
mantel boden mit einer leckeren
waldfrucht einlage und einer vanille
buttercreme und zwar die französische
hier oben drauf habe ich den teddy
gemacht und ein kleines törtchen und das
ganze hier vorne mit zu kleinen fähnchen
deckert und blumen also ein richtig
hübsches gerne hier richtig hübsche
torten einjähriges mädchen
ich werde zuerst einmal zeigen wie ich
die figur und auch die deko elemente
hergestellt habe und die können sie auch
im voraus und herstellen und auch schon
lagern mehrere tage oder schon wochen
vorher
dann habt ihr die nämlich vorbereiteten
habt am tag vor der feier eben nicht
mehr so viel arbeit also starten wir
gleich mit dem modellieren und später
geht's ans backen zum modellieren
verwende ich 120 gramm hellbraune
modelliermasse auswandern und blüten
passte die teile ich jetzt in drei teile
1 und 1 teilen wir zu einem runden kopf
geformt und der zweite teil wird zu
einem tropfenförmigen körper geformt
der kopf wird mit hilfe eines
zahnstochers und essbarem kleber auf dem
körper befestigt
[Musik]
die restliche modelliermasse teile ich
in vier teile ein zum modellieren der
arme und beine
die werden jetzt kegelförmig geformt und
mit einem pre gerat werden die nähte
markiert so sieht dann aus als wäre es
ein echter stoff teddy
[Musik]
rechts und links am kopf markiere ich
zwei löcher für die ohren
die ohren sind jeweils aus einem kleinen
tropfen geformt in die mitte kommt da
noch ein kleines loch
[Musik]
die schnauze des teddys modelliert aus
weißer schokolade
[Musik]
und die details im gesicht markiere ich
mit modelle werkzeug und klebt dann noch
die arme und beine an
[Musik]
hiervor mich jetzt gerade kleine
schleifen aus modell ihr schokolade mit
hilfe einer silikonform die lasse ich
dann trocknen
der teddy ist jetzt leicht angetrocknet
und jetzt werde ich seine wangen noch
ein bisschen rose kudamm nämlich einfach
mit schönen dicken weichen pinsel und
ein bisschen trockene lebensmittel
grüner farbe
und hier habe ich ein kleines stück
modelle schokolade wie ein luftballon
geformt und da kommt jetzt ein drahtseil
und der teddy darf denn dann halten und
dafür nehme ich jetzt das stück trat
dass ich ein bisschen fester da oben
kommt eine schlaufe rein und jetzt muss
ich dich ein bisschen heiß machen
bist du besser aufpassen
[Musik]
und damit wir das täglich rein gesteckt
das was jetzt noch ein bisschen abkühlen
in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon
mal das törtchen machen
[Musik]
und christa ziehen habe ich jetzt hier
drei farben aus modelle schokolade
ausgerollten zwei frauen weiß und
hellblau und wertet kreise ausstechen
und die übereinander kleben
[Musik]
kerze frau mich jetzt aus pink und geht
sie mit einem stück draht fest
[Musik]
die kleinen kekse form ich aus weißer
schokolade und die schoko stücke sind
aus schokoladen fondant gerollt damit
sie etwas realistischer aussehen
befindlich sie dann noch mit kakaopulver
[Musik]
die schleifen bekommen einen schönen
glanz durch die kristall pulver farbe
[Musik]
für die wimpelkette schneide ich kleine
dreiecke in ganz verschiedenen farben
aus
[Musik]
die kleine decke sieht ganz süß aus wenn
man mit hilfe von kleinen ausstellern
und einer loch thüle spitzen musste
einsticht
[Musik]
m
und nun werden noch verschiedene grosse
blumen ausgestochen und zum trocknen auf
eine schaumstoffmatten gelegt
[Musik]
weil viele gerade buchstaben lassen sich
mit hilfe von buchstaben ausstechen
herstellen
[Musik]
die figuren sind jetzt bereits jetzt
kann ich die torte bereits füllen ich
habe jetzt hier einmal eine torte
vorbereitet und zwar ist es ein kuchen
boden der lockere kuchenteig für motiv
torten und darauf habe ich eine
mandelkuchen gemacht als mit ein
bisschen man landtag und die genauen
rezepte findet ihr natürlich auf meinem
blog werde ich ideen von der trocken
unterlage lösen also von der dauer back
folie und nehme keine torten säge und da
gibt es auch die ersatz trete dazu und
ich habe jetzt hier einfach einen
weiteren ersatzrad dazu gemacht und
können dann ist gleich zwei bilden auf
einmal durchschneiden und den stets auf
die richtige höhe ein und schneidet drei
tropfen würden
beim oberen nämlich weg stellen sich ihr
kurz ab und den schutz auch kurz zur
seite denn ich habe jetzt hier auch eine
buttercreme gerichtet war die
französische buttercreme hier ist die
eier creme die ich gewählt habe die
kutsche und ewig kurz die eier creme
untergebuttert und da habe ich jetzt ne
vanillecreme draus gemacht und einfach
zwei teelöffel wandel extrakt reihen
gegeben dann einfach einen richtig
tollen vollen vanille geschmack mit drin
hat
[Musik]
die creme stadt ist auch kurzen seite
und hier habe ich zwei frucht einlagen
gemacht und war dieses mal mit etwas
waldfrucht
jetzt kann die torte bereits gefüllt
werden und ich werde sie auf dieser
tortenplatte film ist dies ein cm stark
und dient dann eben auch zur
präsentation also dass ich eine richtig
schöne stabile trocken werden
da kommt jetzt ein bisschen buttercreme
drauf damit der kuchen gleichstellen
darauf kleben bleibt
da kommt jetzt ein bisschen buttercreme
drauf dann die frucht einlage und so
werde ich die komplette torte füllen
[Musik]
die torten stelle jetzt gleich in den
kühlschrank für etwa eine halbe stunde
bis stunde bis die buttercreme
schulfestes mit der restlichen
buttercreme werde ich sie dann komplett
glatt streichen
[Musik]
die torte ist glatt eingestrichen und
jetzt mit von dort übersehen und dafür
habe ich jetzt ein kilo vanilla von danz
schon weiß geknetet und wetterschutz
dünn ausrollen und die torte damit
beziehen
[Musik]
die tat ist jetzt werde ich eingedeckt
und ich werde jetzt etwa 10 bis 15
minuten kurzen den kühlschrank stellen
damit er von dannen bisschen festwirt
und dann kann ich schon die deko
ankleben gefährlich die torte fans
dekorieren um zuerst wollte skateboard
haben da kommt ein bisschen klee bei den
verstreichen ihren teller die dürfen ist
noch ein bisschen mithelfen und dafür
habe ich jetzt hier nochmal ein stück
vanille fondant einfach ausgerollt das
soll es nämlich nicht seinen vordergrund
treten die skateboard sondern eher ein
bisschen verschwinden
[Musik]
denn rand erfordert der chöre ich mit
einem grünen lebensmittel steckt und
zwar zeichne ich jetzt grill sein
[Musik]
als nächstes kommt ihre kordel außen rum
und zwar soll es hat diese wimpelkette
werden dafür nehme ich die von der
presse geht ein bisschen gelben von land
rein desch und weiß geknetet und habe
davon eine ganz dünne loch scheibe
[Musik]
jetzt schreitet hier lauter gleich lange
stücke ab
[Musik]
jetzt mache ich immer lauter punkte im
abstand von etwa 12 zentimeter
ich hab einfach den umfang der torte
ausgemessen und 84 und werde jetzt
siebenbürgen rein machen und deswegen 12
cm abstand
da kommt jetzt jeweils ein klecks
kilobereich und die werde ich dann die
ketten dran kleben
[Musik]
und jetzt muss ich noch die fähnchen an
die kette kleben
[Musik]
jetzt lebe ich oben die decke noch auf
und zwar ziemlich möchten
den teddy setzt sich jetzt nur drauf
dann nehme ich hier nämlich zum
transport oder runter und setzen dann
vor ort einfach so drauf ohne ihn
anzukleben genauso das törtchen und
achten sie cookies dann habe ich es auch
später beim anschnitt ein bisschen
einfacher und ich habe ich noch ein
marienkäfer von ellerstorfer übrig der
kommt hier auch wird darauf dass kleine
glücksbringer
[Musik]
jetzt ist die torte fertig und sie
gefällt mir wirklich supergut ich finde
vor allem sehr ja eigentlich passte er
von frühling muss ich sagen
sie sind blumen und dem gras hier am
rand von der arbeitszeit her würde ich
jetzt mal schätzen habe ich ungefähr
acht bis neun stunden gebraucht
ich habe etwa eine stunde für den teddy
gebraucht und das hat mich eigentlich am
meisten über auffällt ist das
vorbereiten also das vor backen mit den
böden und daneben die creme die frucht
einlage dann natürlich ist füllen und
bestreichen an sich und am ende sind
dann wichtig diese feinheiten die einen
sehr lange aufhalten
aber natürlich dauert bei uns auch immer
ein bisschen länger weil ich immer alles
mit kamera aufnehmen
aber ich schätze dass er auch so etwas
sechs bis acht stunden bestimmt brauchen
werdet deswegen finde ich es ganz gut
wenn ihr euch das aufteilt und eben die
figuren schon im voraus vorbereitet
falls jetzt diese torte nach machen
wollt dann könnt ihr euch das rezept
nachlesen auch sally blog.de
da steht es noch mal ganz genau ich
werde dort ich hier jetzt natürlich
nicht anschneiden aber wir packen
gleichung versuchen und gehen musste
feier und dann nehmen wir auf jeden fall
noch im papier damit also viel spaß beim
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
und alles gute zum geburtstag luisa
irgendwann in ein paar jahren tauschte
der bestimmtes video von der tante
verliehen
[Musik]